[Musique]
notre joaillier gemmologue marc arnaud a
une affection toute particulière pour
les terres vendéennes
il tenait absolument à me faire
découvrir la plage des sables d'olonne
un lieu emblématique de son enfance est
ce que cette suite a commencé à
s'intéresser à la joaillerie à la
bijouterie à ce qu'il fait on univers
aujourd'hui mon papa il ya été beaucoup
ma maman donc ils révèlent avec quelques
beaux bijoux jeux
je m'amusais à lui nettoyer avant
qu'elles sortent donc elle s'était dit à
un moment donné s'ils se trouvent le
métier de la joaillerie t'intéresserait
et on avait un ami de la famille qui lui
était déjà joaillier et à cette époque
là il travaillait chez chaumet donc il
m'avait fait faire un stage de quatre ou
cinq jours et la côte car oui oui oui
et bien moi j'aimerais bien découvrir la
boutique écoute shturman on est affilié
des diamants des rubis je vais faire des
envieuses
[Musique]
tout en noir oui c'est atypique dans la
forêt amazonienne
ça fait la jungle c'est ça c'est le
décalage qu'on avait souhaité
quand tu as fait ça t'a pas on peut
avoir de plus près bien sûr tu vas bien
sûr la pierre non la pierre est
naturellement comme ça la pression est
là autant nuances de couleurs oui on
passe du but du blanc cassé au bois
turquoise au bleu mer c'est le sait le
principe de l'open d'australie mais
attends c'est un différend d'opale que
tu as en blanc semble donc pas du tout
la fiq a du mal à comprendre
non c'est impressionnant donc c'est la
pièce telle qu'elle que tu as juste
polis travailler même pas elles étaient
polis elle a été extraite et seulement
poli et après moi je la sublime juste en
faisant le montage autour les aborigènes
une une petite une petite légende par
rapport à l'opal il raconte qu'au
commencement du monde à la création du
monde à dieu est descendu sur le
continent australien pour y donner la
vie et il y a descendu à l'aide d'un arc
en ciel et quand il est reparti l'arc en
ciel a laissé toutes ses couleurs dans
la terre ce qui a donné naissance à
l'opal temps pas très bien des pierres
on sent bien que des campagnes
oui cet anime tout de suite ça serait
relié voyager se fait partie de ces
trésors que nous nous donne la terre
temps là d'autres que je peux admirer à
par l'opal d'australie
[Musique]
ouah non nains saphirs jaunes
par exemple ce qu'il faut savoir que le
saphir n'est pas que bleus on trouve des
saphirs de toutes les couleurs et il ya
que le rouge qui est appelée ruby donc
ça c'est un saphir jours et ça c'est un
symbole un chien bleu saphir bleu saphir
rose ça impressionne saphir violet et ça
aussi c'est un saphir non ça c'est une
aide marine du coup tu vas différents
sites et ginola excuse moi ça aide tu
vois j'aime beaucoup les s'affirme là
j'en découvre une auto pas trop ce que
c'est
je trouve très jolie cette pierre
également alors ça c'est un rubis
étoiles et toiles et oui c'est la
famille derby toujours c'est la famille
des cordes ont donc c'est la même
famille que le saphir et tout cela en
sont alors ceux là sont des saphirs et
celui ci est paru hui les détails ça se
complique
ça c'est un saphir oui ça c'est un
sachiez que je vous montre franchement
séquelles très différents le saphir
étoiles est très particulier c'est une
wii ces îles sont la plupart du temps
taillé en cabochon comme ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya pas deux facettes la matière du
saphir étoiles et c'est une matière très
incluse on a énormément de ce qu'on
appelle des petites aiguilles de rutile
ça donne une pierre presque opaque
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
besoin de facettes en fait on joue pas
sera transmis ce site dit est vrai nom
là dessus on cherche à avoir les toiles
d'où son nom le zafira étoilé et coques
la lumière passe dessus on aperçoit une
étoile
effectivement ça va très bien même et ça
c'est naturel oui c'est naturel alors
finalement comment tu fais pour
distinguer une vraie pierre une fausse
pire alors on va prendre un exemple tout
simple on va prendre de sa fille par
exemple
donc là tu veux dire qu'on en a appris
un fou là voilà moi spontanément je
t'aurais dit sur la le vrai parce
qu'effectivement il est plus lumineux
mais tu t'appelles loupe l'attaqué de
loupe genre l'experte
et ben écoute pour moi là je vois juste
effectivement celui ci qui est davantage
taillée mais à part ça je donc pour toi
là serait plutôt celui ci mois on vend
ça comme un saphir bleu je le prends
tout de suite effectivement moi je
pourrais te donner ton diplôme de
géologues effectivement le vrai celui ci
c'est sûr mais moi je me suis juste
basée sur la taille donc franchement on
est plein mais j'aurais pu voler je peux
te montrer ce qu'ils valent et
différenciée l'allongement de torture
donc les pierres précieuses ou des uv
également temps en temps alors sont
regardables sous les huées et elles
réagissent différemment en fonction de
la longueur d'onde ce que je te propose
c'est de prendre les deux pieds dans ta
main et tu vas pouvoir observer aux uv
suivant les cheveux longs ou les uv
cours les différentes réactions des deux
pierres je mets la main dans la machine
et avait retrouvé le long que réaction
tu vas
j'ai juste de pierre à bot marron assez
sombre voilà donc là tu es mal action ce
qu'on appelle inerte
exactement il se passe rien non
justement blanche voilà
et maintenant les uv cours ohlala ah bah
oui il y en a une qui restent sombres
nôtres qui est vraiment qui dix ans
presque pâlotte quoi voilà en fait sur
une pierre naturelle
aux uv cours elle va rester inerte et
sur une pierre synthétique
elle va devenir les deux avaient
complètement on dirait du plastoc
ce test là il est il est redoutable
bon je leur pose un double 6 points que
des pinces à d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
regarder dans son maître des traces de
doigts dessus les néophytes comme moi ça
prend ça que les dorades doigt des
traces de fric
ce domaine à l'établi pour qu'elle
puisse voir les différentes étapes de la
fabrication d'un bijou donc on part
d'une petite bande pour faire là certes
issue roues le cerclage si tu veux de la
pierre en elle même on a différentes
pince avec différentes formes
une fois que tu en métal et recuit est
bien mou te permet de pouvoir le mettre
en forme donc là tu adaptes au métal à
la fin de ta pierre absolument donc tu
veux obtenir cette petite forme en
goutte la voilà et c'est us à la main
comme ça vous êtes à pinces voilà au fur
et à mesure jusqu'à arriver au contour
de la pire voulu tu travailles la
monture tu travailles les pierres tout
était joaillier oui quelle est la
différence entre le métier de bijoutier
et le métier de joie liée
le joaillier a la particularité de
préparer l'objet le bijou à accueillir
des pierres
le bijoutier en règle générale ne fait
que de travail que le métal donc toi tu
es bijoutier joaillier voilà on peut
dire ça comme ça donc le pendentif que
tu entres les mains lui a été sorti et
poli donc toutes les finitions sont
établis et maintenant il est plus il est
prêt à être portées ils prêtent portée
oui absolument
demande 4 portes et je pense a reçu
agetur xintian écouter un 10 secondes de
bonheur est ce que ça te foutent
[Musique]
bon marqueur non je sais bien que je
peux pour l'embarquer chez moi donc tu
sais quoi je l'immortaliser tout de
suite avec toi oui prend la photo et
propose veut attendre liszt et ça c'est
le bolliger la créativité de marque est
sans fin un travail exceptionnel qui
mérite un article sur mon blog